well let's uh before we get into all the
domestic stuff let's talk about what's
going on with this this global agenda we
have this story this is a really freaky
story from timcast.com dutch government
shoots live rounds at farmers protesting
mandates lawmakers enacted restrictive
laws to combat climate change
dutch police opened fire using live
ammunition against farmers protesting
the government's mandatory restrictions
and closure of some farms to meet
climate goals set by the european union
this is really fascinating we've got
tons of tweets here i'll break this uh
breaking this down shots fired police
said the tractor drivers attempted to
drive into officers and service vehicles
i got to say if you watch the video
that's not true
it's a tractor that just drives around
like it pulls out it's going going down
the road and then a cop just
fires at him the tractors don't go that
fast right it's like it's like austin
powers yeah you know you guys remember
that scene with the steam roller yeah
yeah the steam roll the guy's like no
are you kidding
here's here's what's really really crazy
about this so in the context of the
georgia guidestones being blown up we um
i can't say too much because we have
some journalists investigating this but
uh let's let me just say that there are
some sources involved who say it appears
to be a politically motivated attack
obviously someone went and blew the
georgia guide stones what they call the
monument to globalism but let me make
this point
we have a fertilizer shortage because of
the war with russia and ukraine
we have russia and ukraine reducing
their exports of food to neighboring
nations which is supposed to cause a
global famine
and at the same time as we're being
warned about all this at the same time
we're hearing you know germany other
countries panicking over a lack of fuel
european nations are telling their
farmers to stop farming here's the
crazier thing we're being told we're
going to get hit by rising food costs
a lower crop yield and potential food
shortages in the united states and we're
even hearing from people in the industry
they're chatting us saying farmers in
the us are still being paid not to farm
so what is going on and you forgot to
mention all the food processing plants
that are burning down that the news
isn't covering well so so i mean they're
covering it it's just not in the
mainstream national cycle now i i will
say to that point
we've we've
questioned whether or not it's abnormal
the amount of fires
and so we got uh these fact takers came
after us and they were like tim cass
published fake news claiming that all
these fires were happening
and
our article was bad don't get me wrong
like we had some errors that's true but
we did some digging and it looks like
it's slightly above average the amount
of that's normal i saw the list that
went on and on and on i'm like wow and
this i really haven't seen much on it so
there's there's you know what tens of
thousands of warehouses tens of
thousands of factories fires happen
you what we got to be careful of is
sometimes like a car crash happens near
a building and then people are like oh
what was this but what i can say is even
on that story it does look like there
are more there's more fires than there
there have been over the past few years
by a small amount so
take it for what it is either way i'll
say this these fires are a new story
because we're being told there's going
to be a food shortage more importantly
if these fires are happening and they
aren't normal isn't that grounds to tell
farmers to pick up production get up
yeah start producing we have we have the
same thing because of water issues in
arizona there's a lot of fields that are
fallow that you're just not putting any
you know you're not planting
and there's obviously a concern you know
we talk about water issues in arizona
but i say if we keep
handling water issues with more
restrictions restrictions we hurt the
farming and then we have a food shortage
and it sounds like
they're setting us up for a food
shortage amazing why would you tell
farmers not to farm is it because they
don't have transport to get the fog the
food out and they don't want rotten food
but that's incumbent upon the farmers to
figure out not the government to come in
and prevent
right you know farmers are so busy that
they don't mess around i'm from iowa
which is an agriculture state originally
and if you've got farmers protesting and
spending days and nights doing this
you've really pissed off the wrong
people well so so
we can talk about fallowing fields and
all that stuff and government
paying farmers not to farm but in the
netherlands why are they this is about
climate change they're telling these
farmers to reduce emissions and things
like that because of climate goals
do they not suspend these things when
they're like hey a global famine is
coming and europe is going to starve
because ukraine's being invaded by
russia this makes literally no sense and
then to see the police open fire on them
it just reeks of
the global agenda is collapsing it's a
climate change agenda that's what
they're doing joe biden has said who's
campaigning we're going to get off
fossil fuels now what happens he's
shutting down oil and gas leases he's
banning fracking and other oil leases on
public lands and uh we just found out
joe biden
allowed five million barrels of our
strategic reserves to be exported this
country to china of all places not just
but europe and asia as well something
doesn't make sense with what they're
doing and you look at you look at all
this stuff and it really does feel like
like just joe biden's crooked as they
come
oh i mean
that's a fact
we've known about this for a while you
look at the laptop you see everything
that's on that laptop and you see
evidence of dealings with our enemies
financial dealings that should have been
told by the way before the election but
you know that we'll say that for another
day
um he never puts america first
no it's more like biden family first
biden family first his friends in china
first his friends in ukraine you know 58
billion dollars of our taxpayer money
has gone to ukraine and we have a crisis
at the border i mean we've got families
who are struggling they can't make ends
meet they can't afford the groceries
they can't afford to put gas in their
car
and we're sending our hard-earned money
to ukraine
this is insane and then and then you add
on top of it the left
pushing these environmental
mandates on us to the point of
trying to i don't know i don't know what
the point is actually are we trying to
save other animals by hurting the human
race
i i i kind of feel like
you know you see these posts from
democrats when the ukraine war kicked
off and they were saying things like
five you know four dollars a gallon is
the price to pay to see ukraine be free
and things like that you had joe biden
say gas prices will remain high as long
as it takes for ukraine to win
i encourage all of the democrats to run
that slogan in november and in 2024 so
when the voter walks up to the gas pump
and they're picking up the gas pump and
looking at the five bucks a gallon and
then those little tv plus little tvs
play and it'll be like breaking news joe
biden says you got to pay for ukraine
keep saying it keep saying and see if
you win and did one of his uh his
advisors say this the gas prices are
going to remain high until we get the
liberal world order oh yeah he said it's
the what did he say
sure
and it was basically like we're going to
suffer in america because we need to
prop up the liberal world order which is
the decimation of america which is the
decimation of the middle class the
working class they've been working at
this for a generation now and it started
back in the i think it started back in
the 80s when they started closing up the
manufacturing and the political elite
sold out our companies to
china it was in 1946 is when it began
they started the liberal economic order
in 1946 to prevent world war three they
were like we need to set up a world
police and eisenhower warned us about it
he's like yo this military-industrial
complex he called it but they started
out they used american military as the
as the tip of the spear and then now
they're using the american economy with
the federal reserve they're making it
print a bunch of money to to prop up all
this militant activity to prevent world
war iii it did work for the time but i
don't think we need it anymore
personally although maybe we do because
we have things like bricks which is like
uh china russia india that have their
own kind of economic order well bricks
just is the is an acronym for the
countries brazil russia india china
south africa yep that's really easy to
run and it's like one or the other i
don't know if we if there isn't some
sort of global militant stand standard
there's something i think that biden is
more loyal to bricks than us well so we
actually i haven't heard from newsweek
it was biden advisor brian d saying this
is about the future of the liberal world
order and we have to stand firm here's
what's amazing
ten years ago
if you were to bring up something like
that you were a crackpot if you said
here is this isn't it so amazing if you
came out and said there are global
elites
orchestrating what's happening around
the world for for their special interest
they called you a crackpot now they come
out on tv and say it they just go on cnn
and say this is what we're doing here's
the best part
there was a poll i saw and it said
something like 53 of republicans believe
that the world is being run by a a ring
of
a global elite international what you
say child abusers okay and it was framed
as though these people were crackpot
crazy conspiracy theorists like
pizzagate stuff and it's like you look
at that story and then a week later
they're like elaine maxwell sentenced to
20 years for the elite global
trafficking among world leaders and we
don't know where client list is
now look you want to argue that that is
the the um intent behind what they do
internationally i don't know what we do
know is epstein maxwell well that
happened now we'd like to know who they
were dealing with we know that a bunch
of people global elites were flying on
those planes but my point ultimately is
this
it was a conspiracy theory 15 years ago
now we actually just read the news about
maxwell getting convicted getting sent
into 20 years now it's all just
happening and we see the guy saying uh
liberal world order isn't that crazy i
suppose they want us to think that
they're not smart or organized enough to
do any of this with malicious intent and
i think that's what biden hides behind
is that everyone views him as this
senile
old man
but that's the joke
well we made the joke that you know
biden goes up on stage and he's like uh
we gotta come on you know
better calf care and then everyone
laughs then he walks off stage bro and
then as soon as he's behind the scenes
he goes all right where was i i want you
to bomb those kids we're invading let's
go send 60 billion to ukraine ukraine
it's kind of sick if he is like okay
with being the laughing stock
it's really sick to think that his son
biden or his son hunter has been like
the i guess the brains behind a lot of
these financial
uh illegal financial
dealings that that
vice well president biden has been
behind i i think he's the proxy i think
hunter biden is the tool that joe uses
to skirt the law
why so look he flew to china on air
force two he brings hunter along with
him hunter biden does these private
equity deals with china
i think that's all joe
so joe makes the arrangement and then
hunter kind of signs on the dotted line
i mean think about it there's there's
laws
um i mean look at look at how any rich
person tries to evade taxes or give
money to families like you can't do it
right
we got reports that joe and hunter were
sharing bank accounts so here's the here
i'll give you the simple hypothetical
joe biden goes to uh ian as vice
president and says i'm going to build
some buildings in your country it's
going to be great that your economy is
going to boom
my son needs a favor though totally
unrelated
then the country does a deal or special
interest who deals with his son and he
goes don't look at me what my son does
his own business i don't even ask him
about it i don't talk to him about it
remember he said that then we got a
photograph of him with hunter and his
business associates and now we have a
voicemail of joe saying i read the piece
it looks like you're in the clear he
actually said that yeah i think joe is
doing the deals and he's using his son's
name to collect the money that's why in
that email they were like 10 for the big
guy these people are correct yeah all i
know is it's a messed up family i don't
want to i don't want to go too deep into
the election but i don't feel he should
be in the white house
and well he's run this country into the
ground he's run the country into the
ground and that's one of the reasons i'm
fighting so hard in arizona because
we're not going to let him take arizona
down with him
and it's going to come to the states
each state to say no back off we'll
we're going to go back to states rights
here and protect our own people i dig it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there